hey friends so if you have any
familiarity with po whatsoever then you
have seen this move right here the 3B
weave not only is it one of the most
recognizable poy tricks out there but by
learning it we also learned some
specific techniques that helps us out
with a lot of other poy tricks down the
road so I want to take you through some
of those techniques in this video
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I'm going to take you through
the 3B weave using five specific steps
that are going to teach you all kinds of
skills that are going to come in real
Handy down the road but before we dive
in I want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark bunk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyrot teror light
toys spinballs and Ultra poy for help to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca beckin thank
you so much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission all right so if you
follow this channel then you know that I
already uploaded a tutorial on the 3B
weave earlier this month so what gives
why does this video exist well the short
answer to that is that the previous
video that I did was one wherein I
specifically wanted to teach people how
to get the trick down as fast as
possible if they just really wanted to
get from point A to point B the purpose
of this video is going to take you
through some specific steps in learning
the 3B weave that are centered more
around techniques that are going to be
super useful down the road and
specifically we're going to go through
five unique stages so without further
Ado let's go ahead and jump
in Step One split
time so there are a couple different
ways that we can work on split timing
depending upon how familiar that might
be to you already so for example if you
learned how to do double Dutch jump
roping growing up then you already have
some familiarity with using a split
timing and just so it happens to be with
jump ropes instead of with POI but if
that's something that you don't already
have in your wheelhouse there's an
exercise I can give you that involves
practicing the timing of your hand
against a wall that will be super
helpful in getting it down so let's go
find a wall and check that out so the
idea here is that you're going to start
off with both of your hands to one side
of your body and you want to make sure
that they stay in contact with the wall/
mirror in front of you you're going to
go ahead and bring your right hand up
and your left hand down and you're going
to wind up in a position where your arms
are split on your Center Line and then
you're going to move them both all the
way over to your left from here you're
going to bring your left hand up and
your right hand down so once again they
are split along your center line but
separate and bring them back together
over to the right so you want to sweep
your hands back and forth across the
wall/ mirror splitting them top and
bottom and bringing them together to
either side this particular version of
it of course is split time opposites but
we're going to be able to apply it to
being able to do it in Split times same
direction as well and I I'll show you
how to do that when we head back to the
studio here's what we're going to do
next you're going to want to try and
wrap up the poy around your hands and
then let out one coil of the Poise so
they're about elbow length and you're
going to go ahead and see if you can do
that same motion and make your POI
extensions of your hands and arms as
they go around in that split time
opposites timing here when that gets to
feel natural you want to let them all
the way out to full length again they
should just be extensions of your arms
as they go around in this split timing
here now thus far it's been really
useful to think of the wall in front of
you as being a way to kind of keep your
hands switched into the proper motion
here but now we're going to get rid of
that wall and instead we're going to
kind of move the planes outward a little
bit away from us so it's almost like
we're kind of creating a little egg
beater with our with our hands here from
here we want to push all the way out so
that we're keeping the same timing but
we're no longer crossing our hands past
each other now they're kind of walking
on either side of us and when you get to
this point
congratulations this is split Time same
direction and more specifically we're
doing split Time same direction in what
we would call Wheel plane so let me show
you what that looks like from your
perspective
[Music]
[Applause]
all right fabulous so now that you've
got your split timing down we're going
to talk about how you get that PO back
and forth across your body when you
perform those
weaves step two Tic
Tacs so just like when we learn split
timing we're going to want to do this
with our hands first and then get our
point to follow so follow along with me
as I navigate you through what your
hands need to do here first and foremost
we're going to do this with our right
hand so I'm going to have you stick your
right hand straight out in front of you
and we're going to begin by doing a spin
with your hand SLP on your right side uh
by the way you want to make sure that
your PO is all wrapped up here just in
case that's not clear so you're going to
go ahead and from right out in front of
you you're going to drop your right hand
next to your right hip it's just going
to pass by there and then you're going
to turn your upper body just a little
bit to the right and reach your arm back
past your right shoulder before reaching
directly up above your right shoulder
and bringing your hand down directly in
front of you second part of this is that
we're going to reach that hand down next
to the left hip then we're going to
reach it back past the left shoulder
directly up above the left shoulder and
straight out back in front of us again
it's down past our left hip back behind
our left shoulder up above our left
shoulder and straight out in front so Al
together then we want to sweep past the
right hip behind the right shoulder
above the right shoulder straight out in
front sweep it past the left hip behind
the left shoulder up above the left
shoulder straight out in front do a
circle on the right boom do a circle on
the left boom you'll notice as I'm doing
this I'm using this point where my hand
is reaching straight out in front of me
to switch between the circle on my right
side and the circle on my left side but
it's always going to feel as though my
hand is kind of turning around forwards
in relation to me here's what it looks
like from the side I do down past the
right hip and back around down past the
left hip back around right hip around
left hip around like so all right cool
so if the hand motion is feeling
comfortable we're going to bring our poy
into it once again we're going to start
with the POI wrapped all the way around
our hand and we're going to let out a
single coil so it's about elbow length
and we're going to treat the POI as an
extension of our hand and arm so we're
going to reach around and do a circle on
the right then on the left on the right
and then on the left and then I'm going
to let out the PO two full length and
again circle on the right circle on the
left circle on the right circle on the
left as I get to feel more comfortable
with this I can take some of the motion
out of my hand and arm and put more of
it into the POI So eventually it's just
the POI doing this just the POI going
circle on the right circle on the left
going back and forth and of course you
want to repeat all of these same steps
with your left hand hand thinking that
from your left hand in front you want to
drop down to your left hip behind your
left shoulder above your left shoulder
straight out next to your right hip
right shoulder above your right shoulder
and then straight out again circle on
the left circle on the right circle on
the left circle on the right with the
hand passing through that point that's
straight out in front of you in the
process of this and then you want to go
ahead and lat out one coil the POI and
thank circle on the left circle on the
right circle on the left circle on the
right let the PO out to full length and
think circle on the left circle on the
right circle on the left circle on the
right like so and from the front we have
circle on the left circle on the right
let me show you that from your
perspective
[Music]
awesome sauce okay so now we have to
work on coordinating the two hands
together so that'll be our next
step step three the two beat
weave so as with most things here I
think it's helpful to start off with
just our hands and the POI wrapped up to
understand what the motion here is so
whenever we're doing a TW beat weave we
are also working in a place where only
one hand is really good to go on top of
the other one and I'm going to start off
with my right hand going on top of my
left now counterintuitively whenever
you're talking about one hand going over
the other it's actually the hand that
goes under that starts the motion so I'm
going to take you through this step by
step here so I'm going to start this off
by having my left hand hopping up and
over and arriving over at my right side
I'm then going to take my right hand hop
it up and over on top of my left hand
and then my left hand is going to sweep
back down and around over to the left
and the right hand is going to sweep
back down and around back to the right
again left up and over to the right
right up and over to the left the left
goes down and round to the left and the
right goes down and round back to the
right okay so now let's get the PO
involved go ahead and let the PO out to
full length there's really no sense in
doing this with shorter po uh and we're
going to go ahead and just start with
the POI spinning forwards on the left
hand side the left hand goes over to the
right the right hand goes over to the
left the left hand pulls back out and
around the right hand pulls back out and
around let me show you that from the
side here so the left hand swings up and
over right hand swings up and over left
hand swings back out and around right
hand swings back out and around all
right so now we want to see if we can
connect the dots here and make this go a
little bit faster so I'm going to go
ahead and start with the PO on my left
hand spinning and I'm going to bring it
over right hand goes over left hand
comes out right hand comes out again
left over right over left out right out
again we want to see if we can speed
this up a little bit so sometimes it
helps at this point to have both of the
pois spinning at our sides so we're
going to think left over right over left
out right out again we think left over
right over left out right out and really
in the end what this is going to wind up
feeling like is you're going to think
left under right over and open left
under right over
open and at that point that is a two
beat weave with the right hand on top
and yes indeed we also have to learn it
with the left hand on top too all right
so we're going to go ahead and speedrun
this and quick reminder that whichever
hand is going on top it's actually the
opposite hand that starts it so we want
to think right hand jumps to the left
left hand jumps to the right right hand
pulls back to the right left hand pulls
back to the left again we have the right
hand jumps over to the left the left
hand jumps over to the right the right
hand pulls back to the right left pulls
back to the left we want to think right
left right left right left right left we
want to get the PO involved so we're
going to think right left right left
right left right left from the side we
think right left right left right left
right left and doing it all together
then we want to than right left right
left again right left right left like so
and then we have the two beat weave down
with the left hand going on top every
time outstanding here's both of those
from your perspective
[Music]
[Applause]
and with that in mind we're ready to go
to step
four step four the short 3B
weave so what I want you to do is go
ahead and stick your left hand out and I
want you to practice taking your right
hand over it back and forth we're only
doing two Beats at this point but we
want to do 10 reps bringing the right
hand back and forth on top of the left
hand when that gets to feel comfortable
we now want to practice doing 10 beats
going back and forth underneath the left
hand and of course we want to do the
same thing with the left hand and the
right hand sticking the right hand
straight out and doing 10 reps of taking
the left hand POI over it and then 10
reps taking the left hand POI under it
like so so from here as we are doing our
two beats over on our non-native side
we're going to work on shifting that
hand from being over the opposite hand
to being under it here's how that works
as I switch over my first beat is going
to be over my left hand and as I switch
to doing the underbeat I'm letting the
poy as it's moving forward away from me
carry it around essentially tracing a
path around my left hand to winding up
underneath it so I do a beat on top
follow the PO around underneath and back
do a beat on top follow the PO around
underneath and go back you want to think
of this pattern as being over under back
over under back you want to get that
down with the left hand too thinking
you're doing over under back over under
back here's what that'll look like from
your perspective
[Music]
so real quick before we take that final
step and finish up our three beat weaves
if you're interested in taking your
learning deeper then I have an awesome
option for you and that is to check out
the flow circle on my patreon the flow
circle is a weekly exclusive lesson that
is available only to my patreon
subscribers throughout the month of May
I have been sharing a number of
different lessons about the three beat
weave from how to use it to explore
volume to adding and subtracting beats
to each side and the final lesson of the
month which is going to be on the
isolated 3B weave if you'd like to take
your learning A little bit further
please go check it out at
patreon.com drexfactor poy all right
sweet so let's take our final step and
finish up that 3B
weave step five putting it all
together all right so let's go ahead and
start with the version of the two beat
weave that involves the right hand going
over top remember that starts with our
left hand so when we do the right hand
going on top we have to let it do an
extra beat over on our left hand side so
that our left hand can reach around over
it the way I like to describe this to
people is that you have to do a beat
with the right hand in your left armpit
you want to think the right goes over
and then it does an extra beat in the
armpit and then you can unwrap again we
want to think the right goes over it
does a beat in the left armpit and then
you can unwrap awesome so just like we
did with the right hand we want to think
the left goes over and then it gets in
an extra beat in the right armpit and we
come out of it again the left goes over
it gets in an extra beat in the right
armpit and it comes back over sometimes
what happens with h people trying this
out is they'll try and cross and then
uncross and then go back we don't want
to do that we want to keep the left hand
over on the right hand ins side as the
right hand reaches around on top of it
so I actually want you to practice
getting in 10 reps on each side so
thinking that the right hand goes over
then in the armpit and back out and then
the left hand goes over then in the
armpit and back out again the right hand
goes over then in the armpit back out
and the left hand goes over then in the
armpit back out when you can do 10 reps
going back and forth like that then it's
time to just see if you can go straight
back and forth between them you're going
to think that the right hand goes over
the left hand goes over right hand goes
over left hand goes over you know that
you're doing this right when you're
constantly switching which hand is on
top and your hands and POI are not
tangling into each other here's what it
looks like from the side thinking right
over left over right over left over just
like that let me show you that from your
perspective
[Music]
awesome friends so that is the 3B weave
but specifically taught in a way where
I'm giving you techniques that are going
to be super useful throughout your POI
Journey did you learn anything new in
the course of this I really hope so if
you got down the three beat weave as a
result of watching this video please
make sure to post video of yourself
performing it and tag me I am @
drexfactor on all the platforms please
make sure to like comment share and
subscribe to help other people find this
video and to help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much for
helping me and supporting my channel my
work and my mission and if you out there
watching also enjoy the content that I
make and you'd like to see me make more
of it there is a very easy way that you
can help me do so more in the future and
that is to sign up on my patreon over at
patreon.com Factor poo there you can get
access to a whole host of awesome
rewards but even better than that you'll
be supporting me in my mission to bring
po spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world go check that out please and
thank you and if you're watching this
video and wished that you had learned
the other technique for getting down the
3B weave which will work inside of 30
minutes I'm pretty sure I will go ahead
and link to that video down in the
description as well as up on screen
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace